[Music]
for the six seven months building up to
the tour it's just making sure every
little thing is is heading towards
trying to win the Tour de France the
nutrition is a cornerstone to
performance you can train all you want
but if you're not feeling properly and
getting in with the right kind of
nutrients you're gonna crash and burn
sooner or later so for a writer like
Chris who really believes in higher
nutrition can influence performance you
know we'll start thinking burlap in
December 2016
and the way that we do that is to try
and use nutrition to drive training
obsessions in a framework words meal by
meal but also day-by-day we consistently
consume high protein what we do is we
paralyze the carbohydrate for oven when
we heat up and that means that we work
very closely with the coach we work very
closely with Chris we collect all of our
feedback we're constantly monitoring all
of that data just to make sure that
we're on track for what we need to
achieve six months down the line this
last couple years we've really been able
to get a good consistency of messages
across dividers and people are really
into the the products that we use it
Grand Tours represent our biggest
challenge really you know when you think
about it we've got 21 days of riding
four five and six hours in device for
streaming and nutritional challenges for
us the first one is making sure that we
have fuel to perform each day but also
that we recover to perform a consecutive
day the second one is that we manage
people's works during the three weeks
now we don't want to put on with what
was certainly don't want to lose with
with James's input and his attention for
detail and the way in which he uses
science in sport products to sort of
help his monitor and maintain weight has
been really good and then last but not
least is making sure that people don't
get oh and you know in the 2016 Tour de
France we did a great job about that was
the first time we had nine riders
actually get over the line and that was
a real big achievement for us
[Music]
so one of the things that we try and do
in the Grand Tour is we fear keep speed
in isolation because every state is
different but then also all of those
stages can add up to represent real hard
times in the wrist two or three make
sometimes four-day blocks and we try and
work with the coaches to predict the
energy requirements for those particular
stages and then of course we can fuel
each stage differently every rider will
go into the stage with their own
specific fueling plan have you stick to
the plant and then hopefully success
will happen I really like having
everything of plans before the event I
know when I'm going to eat certain
things and I know I've got enough with
me to the last curation of the event
so for Michael's leaders we try and
split it into three components of the
risk really the first part of the risk
is merely solids so that could be rice
cakes or could be energy bars and the
second third of the risk event I need
the translucent semi solids which of
course is gels and then in the last
third of the risk right before the
Kleins we eliminate the transition to
caffeine gels we want people to hit that
climb really and if in a fresh mindset
strong mindset and that's why we believe
that we can use caffeine strategically
when we're racing it's pretty much all
thinking about what's actually happening
in the race getting things right with
fueling strategies and what's what's
coming up so time trials represent a
somewhat different nutritional challenge
actually because of course it's assured
their effort but it's also a much more
high intensity effort which kind of mean
through the fuels a hundred percent by
carbohydrate in training you want to do
exactly what you're going to be doing
the race pace is you don't want to go
into a race having not had a certain gel
or or drink so the first thing that we
have to ensure is that the rider when
they turn up to risk is capable of
utilizing those carbohydrates as a fuel
source so they exploit that time
traveling light and that they can just
generate those real high intensity
efforts in the 24 hours before racing
you're really really dialing in on the
whole nutritional side of things you
want to be well fuels but not bloated
you don't have too much sodium intake
the day before you want to go into the
race retaining a lot of water so for
flat feet is in particular for the
initial advice with you that maybe you
don't have to fuel as much as you would
have to do it on a bulking speeds but we
also try and get the riders into the
mindset you know anything can happen to
the bikers it can be very unpredictable
so don't get caught up actually so
although we try and say two riders to
manage your fueling trip on the flatter
speeds we also make sure they have that
mindset that increase the risk goes off
they're ready to go as well
there are some a flat fees because the
intensity might not be as higher than
our predominant fueling strategy with
the more solid Eclipse or perhaps more
likely Explorer bars we would make the
transition to gels towards the end of
the skids
and we would probably use less caffeine
gels on a flat fee as Axl I've enjoyed
working with SAS certainly for we need
in terms of long endurance events I
think I think we're completely covered
[Music]